hey everyone welcome to the walleye
podcast i'm james marshall and firstly
thanks to all the responses to my
request for an intro or a jingle
that i put up on instagram i had a lot
of messages from people
asking me why i don't have a jingle yet
so i thought i'd just chuck it on my
instagram page and see if anyone was
keen to give it a go
and blown away with the response i had
four attempts
straight away in the first half an hour
from people so i had to take it down so
really appreciate the effort from you
four guys who are keen to give it a
crack
they're all really awesome attempts but
this one is my favorite so shout out to
alex malcolm
yes the legend of marty banks and
alexander hammer for coming together and
creating this
jingle it's been stuck in my head for
the last week so hopefully you guys
enjoy it
so this is the water lad jingle here you
[Music]
go
[Music]
how good is that it's been stuck in my
head for days like i said
i'm a big fan of it hopefully you guys
enjoy that too but anyway let's get to
today's episode as we have a current
star of international rugby scene and
he's only 24 years old
this welsh rugby legend has had an
incredible journey to the top
but it hasn't all been smooth sailing
for the kid he first started out at
london irish at the tender age of 18
he then went on to play for england at
the under 20s world cup where he played
a starring role for them
he then moved up to the newcastle
falcons and he's currently with
the scarlets and wales where he's
obviously playing international rugby
for wales
and of course like all my guests he is
an absolute lad it is johnny williams
welcome john boy
hey good to be on mate thanks for having
me hey what do you think of the jingle
mate it's good what a jingle
your head was bombing you were into it
are you a hero yeah i was loving life
i'm loving life it's good to see you
mate it's been so long as well hasn't it
yeah it sure has been good to see your
face on the big screen now i've still
been following your career closely and
matt you've been going so good it's been
awesome to see yeah i know
just um the highs and lows of sport i
guess you know so
yeah i had a little um injury patch
recently with my concussion but now i'm
back on the pitch now
and hopefully it goes well matt talking
about highs and lows mate your career
has been the ultimate
highs and lows eh like you've had some
real highs in your career and you've hit
some real lows but
no doubt we'll get into that throughout
the podcast but
how's the six nations with wales been
you guys have been on fire what's it
been like being in that camp
yeah really good mate um yeah the
training's
intense and hard um but yeah it's a
winning camp and it's a good one
so far so good obviously at the start
i've had the star against ireland
only played 20 minutes um so that was
obviously the high
and then being injured with concussion
and stuff
which is you know the highs and lows of
course and but
we were going really well winning every
game and it's a winning camp a good camp
and you know it's a shame that we pulled
up short against france but
mate it was uh it was a good camp and so
you were available the last couple of
weeks were you or have you are you still
out with your head not
no no i'm about fit so um i was back fit
for
uh england italy and france and just
yeah missed out on selection basically
so yeah good about that but
the boys are doing well and there's a
winning team so it's hard to get back in
once those boys are going well
yeah and you've also got some quality
midfielders over there at the moment so
haven't you
yeah really experienced class british
and archline centers and then
willis hale hollow did you you played
with him at the canyons didn't you yeah
good say
yeah yeah good good fee good player good
lad what a left
he needs to get on what a lap yeah get
him on go on so yeah
i know so yeah tough once i had my shot
and i had my shot but
i get i guess only 20 minutes and it's
not like
you know i didn't go well and i didn't
go badly not much i could have done
in that 20 minutes but when when the
boys are winning and
and going as well as they were it's hard
to
play myself back in and with jonathan
davis and george north george north's
got 100 caps jonathan davis
80 80 odd caps so british and arch lions
you know it's hard to yeah hard to get
in the squad when those boys are going
so well
so you said you weren't going that well
but you were carving it up you were even
named
and sam warburton's team to tour south
africa
for the british and irish lions starting
12. how good was it
yeah he took a punt didn't it
a thousand to one outsider lazarus
[Laughter]
yeah so um i doubt i'll be in uh in that
you'd name me in that again but um you
know if i if i have the game time again
hopefully i can prove that i should be
but you know here's what it is
yeah because i know when people get um
put into teams like that
you usually caught more abuse than
anything from people like well what's he
hanging there did you cop nah not to be
honest
um i had a little i didn't look a look
at a little look at the comments but um
and they were like who is
who that that um so yeah i had a good
old giggle about it but that is
obviously
you know from sam waltman you know
really
privileged to be named well in his in
his team but
yeah it would probably be different now
even the like the welsh fans are pretty
brutally like um even in the weekend
i saw the um post from the rugby union
of
the abuse liam williams copped after
that game it was all pretty
brutal stuff eh so is it quite a bit of
that over there
um i've not experienced much of that
myself but as you said because it was
such a big game
and there was so much riding on it
obviously and the whole of the nation
would have been watching that game
but you know it's just still
unacceptable isn't it
you know to be saying that death threats
the abuse that he
caught and not just him other boys cops
but because he
i guess he is a high profile player he
did get so much more but
it's still unacceptable you know you
can't just i get
obviously the disappointment of not
winning but it wasn't like
he you know i think he got a lot of the
abuse for getting the yellow card but
it's not like that alone cost us the
grand slam so there's not even that much
truth from what they're saying anyway
but yeah no i've not experienced yeah
that much but
i'm sure i'm sure i will cop some abuse
by the fans when they're back
once they know who you are yeah
yeah exactly oh but anyway let's crack
and
uh crack into your journey let's go
right back to the start for young johnny
williams what was it what was it like
for you growing up
um yeah so you know my dad was
my big rugby influence in life so he's
he's also the welsh connection welsh
speaking so yeah so he he obviously got
me
into rugby and yeah being being around
here london irish was the
was my academy that i was brought up
from so and that's where i met jimmy
marshall what i led
so um so yeah and
since london irish then i transferred
them to newcastle falcons
and then obviously to scarlets and and
now doing well to get into the squad so
so yeah it feels right that i've i've
taken that path
and to play international rugby for
wales because that was my rugby
influence
through my dad who showed me rugby and
also the welsh influence as well so
yeah so far so good you've just skipped
through your whole career in
one sentence yeah i don't know i don't
want a boy
[Laughter]
but so you obviously made the london
irish at 18 years old so that's so young
to be
making your debut for them so how did
that come about how did you
how did you get into this so quickly you
must have been a schoolboy sensation
well so i was at london irish then and
tom coventry and clark laidlaw were
doing the attack and
um a couple injuries and i was lucky
enough to be given a shot in the
challenge cup against
ajahn yeah and i've got my match in that
game
and went well and so since i had that
opportunity i just kind of
ended up keeping the shirt so you know
as you said 18 10 and 19 and that year
was such a big year for us because i
think we
were bot in the league looking like we
were going to be relegated
so it was almost like i was on such a
high from
you know being being the starter and
first year out of school
but the pressure was massively on to to
keep
keep us up and it was almost like you
know at school you're just having fun
having a crack with your lads and then
it was very much the
the scary world of the professional
rugby which was all about winning
and staying up and these are must-win
games where
i wouldn't say it's enjoyable but you
know i was just happy to be there
playing in the prem
so playing against some of my idols yeah
and so it's it's a it's a wake-up call
just chucked in a deep end as you like
did you did you always feel confident
going
into that environment like obviously so
young were you were you confident you
could compete at that level even though
you hadn't experienced any of it
um i wouldn't say yeah i had doubts you
know you
if you're chucked onto that stage you're
like am i physical enough am i good
enough
but within within a couple of games i
had i had quite a good start and i
and then you just get the
self-confidence from that you know so
um it was almost like i had to prove to
myself and to others that i deserved
to be there um but i look back on that
and
i was chucked in massive games like big
relegation games so young and it's i
still consider myself as young at 24
but it almost feels like i've got that
experience in the bank
100 and one thing that was very obvious
from the outset when you first started
was your ability to get guaranteed gain
line and lightning quick ball
and you still got the best stats and pro
footy with those
how do you do it okay
i just wrote hard but yeah
so um with the game plan it was very
much like
well that's what they wanted from the
12. i don't know if that's what you
thought
when you were there that's what they
really wanted
and i thought i did have a lot more to
my game but i never
got to show that as much because they
just wanted a big crash ball 12.
you know yeah so i've been doing that
from the age of 18
and now it's very much like i want to
show other parts of my game
so hopefully i can i'm doing that
you are so then what was it like going
from already playing in the premiership
to then going across to the
under 20s what was it like that world
cup um
again it was almost like i because we
were playing premiership and there was a
few boys in that under 20 squad who were
playing premiership
yeah we almost brought that experience
with us
and i guess a couple of the boys did
look up to us
because we had that premiership
experience like you said
to to add to the group in the six
nations
um earlier that season i think they came
second last
and then yeah and then all of a sudden
for this for the world cup
we had all the premiership boys come in
and we just
we just added and it went from strength
to strength and and
we ended up winning the six nations it
was almost like a thousand to one
outsiders
so good easter good each way bet
and uh yeah we ended up winning it was
it was fantastic i look back on that
with massive pride you know so
because everyone did doubt us after
having such a bad six nations but
and again everyone's our age good
night's out
after yeah and and as you said we did
get
relegated that season so it was almost
like such a negative yeah so then go to
there and win the world cup and it was
like right
okay i can be part of a winning team an
ad
and i actually enjoy my rugby a little
bit
so was was your decision for you to make
when you decided to play for the england
under 20s
um so age my age grade stuff was quite
complicated so
yeah i i ended up playing wells on the
16s but i didn't originally make wales
under 16s or
england southwest so i got called up to
wales under 16s through
an injury luckily enough um and then
from from wales under 16s it went
straight into
under 18s they they skipped out the
under 17 section
yeah so i didn't never got the call up
or make it to under 18s a year early if
that makes sense
whereas england on the 17th this is
where
in my game a bit complicated but england
under 17s called me up so
i went from wales under 16s to then
england under 17. yeah
and i just stayed in in the england
pathway
um since then before then
signing for scarlets and then getting
the call up to international
for wales then true so when you finished
it will cap were your sights on playing
for england
um it's a it's a tough question because
i think that was the that was the
natural progression yeah
but like i like i said earlier my dad
was a massive influence on me in my
rugby career and also
him being welsh and welsh speaking that
was that was the influence to go and
play for wales
so he had a debenture the millennium and
so he he used to take us
as a kid to go watch wells play every
single game
and it was being in the stands watching
with him was the reason i wanted to be
on that pitch was watching wells play
rugby yeah
so obviously well sort of born in
breadth
and things going between that i guess
that was the
natural progression but feels so good
and feels so right and it's almost like
it's come around
that i'm finally on the pitch in the
principality stadium playing for wales
yeah when that was why i wanted to play
rugby you know
being in the stand with my dad watching
wales play and i remember as a young kid
saying i really want to be on that pitch
playing
and yeah ever since then it just feels
so right that i'm doing that now at the
principality for whales i can't explain
it
yeah yeah yeah so it's as you said it's
it's come a long way and it's gone in a
roundabout way
and it's not been a straight path to the
top but
you know it does still feel right that
i'm now playing for wales yeah
so we'll go back to your london irish
because you got you talked about the
relegation
then you got promoted and then you got
relegated again talk me through the
emotions of those couple years um
yeah really really tough when i was when
i was 18 and playing
again i was just happy to be playing and
i was it was almost a compliment that i
was starting at such a young age in the
premiership and in the depend
now yeah getting relegated awful news
whatever
but we had a great year now champ that's
when you came wasn't it that year in the
chat
yeah what a year
yeah so it's uh there's some good
time-offs good good piss-ups in that
year
um but ultimately you don't want to be
you don't want to be there for too long
you want to be in the big time
in the prem but yeah we we weren't able
to do it
um and stay up so i then went to
newcastle falcons then
um whereas it was good up there and
congratulate again what was the reason
behind your decision to go up to
newcastle did you have the opportunity
to stay or go anywhere else
and what was the deciding factor to head
to newcastle um
so that year newcastle came fourth um
you know champions got rugby playing a
really good brand of rugby i felt like
that was the massive difference from us
in london irish we were quite
physical um and a real strong
uh kicking game plan around the time
that's to put it politely
[Laughter]
we hated playing rugby at the night i
love my time there
um so yeah going to newcastle they they
you know play from deep
um love getting their hands their backs
hands on the ball
um i just felt like it would really
improve me as a player
um and just i'm just getting a fresh
fresh start almost um you know that was
my only rugby
rugby influence as an academy and as a
as a team that's the only thing i've
seen so all my opinions and all my
thoughts
i guess were that was how to how to play
so i needed
you know like a fresh set of eyes and a
new way of looking at the game i felt
which would only add another string to
my bow as a rugby player yeah
how did you go up there yeah it went
went well
um from from a rugby point of view yeah
it was really good going really well
um from a from a personal point of view
but as again as a team we
we did struggle that season so you made
that am i right and saying you made of
the english team
to play the barbarians while you're at
newcastle is that yes that's right yeah
i guess the barbers yeah it's hooking
them so how was that
um again really good week um so
our attack coach at newcastle ended up
coming in and taking the attack for
england that week
so i knew again how we wanted to play
and so
i guess i could as a player drive that
coming into that to that england squad
but yeah it was a good week it was a
quite
chill relaxed week because it was two
weeks after the end of the season
yeah so they knew we had a heavy social
celebrating the end of the season
um so it's quite a relaxed week um and
then
playing against the bar bars it was
quite an open game so i was i was so
tired
because it was so open and we've been on
the piss for like two weeks so yeah
um but no it was a good it was a good
camp and it was a good week and then
uh a real setback hit you didn't it and
what was it 2019 you got diagnosed with
testicular cancer so that you've gone
from the high of playing
as close as you can get to international
rugby to
being hit with that bombshell how was
that and how did you find out about that
um that was a real
tough time in my life i guess um of
course it was
[Music]
and it's it's it's quite a long story
but
i i guess we've got time and we jim
we've got as long as you want
we can make it a mini series so yeah
yeah so
um i knew there was a problem basically
i was in the bath and i knew i had
um my testicle was um
was hard basically and i knew it wasn't
right you just know your body you know
so i went to just a local gp
had some tests they said right fair
enough
you need a scan so i ended up playing in
that england game
and having the five weeks off and that's
for summer you know
so in the back of my head i was told no
lumps or bumps
i just need a scan so i kind of put it
to bed for like five weeks enjoyed my
five weeks
and came and i went back to my my
parents house and reading
in that time in the back of my head i
knew i needed a scan
so i went somewhere to guess a referral
for a scan
they checked it and said no lumps or
bumps i think this is fine
but also we can't refer you to a scan i
said well this is pointless
and so again it was twice i was told
that there was no lumps of bumps but it
was hard
so there was nothing to worry about but
you know your body you know
it's sore and achy and i knew it was
hard so
once i've gone back to newcastle this
was this was three months after now i've
left it for three months
it's swollen up a bit bit larger and it
was it was
we did um we did a contact session
and i got like a slight knock on it and
it must have been aching for about an
hour after i was in agony
and i i just knew that something really
wasn't right and i needed to go and see
the club doctor
yeah so i just dropped my pride went and
saw the club doctor
dropped him a message saying you need to
have a look at this so
he he checks back pretty quickly saying
come to
come to my clinic asap um i've got five
minutes i'll go home so i rushed to his
um he had to look it said how long has
it been like this for i said it's
been like this now for about three
months he was like jesus christ
all right we'll get you in for a scan
booked in tomorrow morning
so when when went for the my scan
just you know getting my getting the
scan done
having a bit of a laugh with him and all
that sort of stuff and
yeah he puts what's it called the
ultrasound
he's finished with the ultrasound and um
he was like i think
you've got a massive tumor in there um
it was it was 44 mil
tumor so you explain this to me
but like we've gone from having a laugh
to right you've got 44 millimeter tumor
in your testicle do i mean so it was
almost like a
what like okay yeah so i didn't really
know how to say that he said don't panic
it might not be
um cancerous um
you you'll go to the oncology and
they'll give you um
they'll they'll tell you the results in
the next steps so again straight away
booked in for the next day then with
oncology
um they said i i see these every day
obviously
that's his job so he said this is 99
malignant
i didn't know what malignant meant at
the time so i was just you know
straight out of my head but it's like
what that means yeah
yeah it basically means cancerous i
didn't know that yeah
um and yeah once it was obviously broken
broken down to me i
the hardest part was telling my parents
that
i've got testing for cancer and what
that meant for me in my career
the question marks over that um
yeah it was really hard time real real
real bad time for me but
looking back now it's it's just made me
a stronger person
geez it's crazy did it ever feel life
threatening no
not not not to be honest because we had
two guys in london irish who
who had tested cancer um and
they were brilliant for me yeah they
gave me a lot of advice andre quinn
yeah did you meet andre wasn't yeah
oh what a lad yeah so he he helped me
massively with my preparation for
the chemotherapy um all the advice in
the world
so he he he helped me massively and
um you know i literally saw him go
through it first hand and so i knew it
wasn't life-threatening as such
but his he did down play
a little bit i guess and he did
massively downplay it and so
um it was ten times harder than i than
i thought it was going to be going
through the especially the key my side
of it i think that was the hardest side
of it yeah
beforehand the surgery it was almost
like a mini injury it was like
the surgery removal of the testicle and
then
i was told if it's not cancerous i could
be
back in the club and rehab him within
within a month
and i was like oh right this isn't too
bad yeah
um but once oncology said we recommend
chemotherapy and go through that and
what that meant
and it was completely different nothing
can ever prepare you for that i guess
and how mentally tough that is
um so so yeah i ended up going through
that
i had one cycle but one cycle was
four days on a 24 7 drip of chemotherapy
and then a week after another half an
hour and then a week after that another
half an hour
yeah so that's one cycle um
and yeah probably yeah definitely the
hardest time in my life
so far yeah what is it about the chemo
is it like what it does to your body or
is it just
like yeah what's that actually like so
it just it just made me it just knocked
me for sex um
just really ill like you've got like the
worst bug you know
i felt nauseous the whole time like i
couldn't move
really out of bed um wanting to be sick
or just feeling like i was going to be
sick but i wasn't actually sick which is
even worse
excited to get it out yeah and
even when you're off here you have
spikes and energy so
i i might i might have a visitor for
example my like my parents or my mom or
dad or
or friends from the club like the
falcons boys came up and saw me quite a
fair bit so they'd come and see me and
i'd get a little spike in energy
and perk up a little bit but the minute
they they would go i'd
absolutely crash and i'll just sleep and
sleep and see but i felt even worse then
yeah like um yeah wanting to be sick the
whole time literally couldn't even turn
over
that ill crazy um and once that that was
the four days in hospital but
even leaving hospital for the week after
it was just
i couldn't get off the sofa uh to
isolate because
my white blood cells were really low so
i'm yeah used to isolate now but because
of that but
uh no as i said it's a real real hard
time
but yeah it did send me for six i wasn't
prepared for that because
i guess i've never seen it i didn't even
know how chemotherapy was taken i guess
um i was kind of quite blind to all that
side of things
but yeah nothing can prepare you for
that that news and
what i went through with that would have
been any different if you got onto it
early if you got that scan straight away
would anything have been different
yeah so they said i needed the chemo
because
it started spreading the cancer cells
had spread into the blood vessels
basically
so if i did catch it earlier yeah i
wouldn't have needed chemo i would have
had the surgery
you know and just rehabbed it rehab the
surgery and be back playing and
it would have been you know over my head
and quite naive about it yeah
but yeah because i i did leave it for
three months
not not necessarily to my fault but
because i was told there was no lumps or
bumps um
yeah i ended up being three months and
then all of a sudden
it started to spread and then i needed
the chemo
from there yeah so yeah that's why
around
the awareness part of it which i feel
like my role is now
is to raise awareness for testicular
cancer but all cancers
and even if one i've had quite a lot of
messages since since i've spoken out on
the fact and
tried to do that um how common
testicular cancer is in men
yeah and so yeah i feel like that's
that's
that's my part and that's what i can add
other than just
you know rugby rugby rugby it gives me a
purpose other than rugby as well which
is
which is good so what stopped you from
going to see your team doctor at the
start
um just pride really just because i i
knew him
yeah and just i didn't fancy it him
seeing my bollocks
yeah so i just went to a gp i didn't
know and
well two gps who i didn't know who said
no lumps or bumps
but yeah i just thought it's easy
after the three months went by and i've
seen two doctors it was then
the best thing just to get the club
doctor who's yeah he was better and
he was really concerned yeah i should
have done that a lot earlier in
hindsight and what what's the key to
finding it early what is it just any
abnormalities
in your testicles yeah because the
doctors
said no lumps or bumps and they were
looking for the lumps of bumps but
i didn't have lumps of bumps i had the
the firmness um
which is which is abnormal so yeah any
abnormalities
to look out for and and be
quite strict and ask the questions like
they're obviously not always
100 correct if you know what i mean so
yeah so pressure them ask the questions
um get answers true but then obviously
you had an amazing recovery and
you were back playing how long was it
before you were back playing
um so i finished chemotherapy
on the 8th of october yeah and
i was back playing in january true
how was that i guess rehab from there or
like recovery to build back into
being a professional rugby player again
did you lose much weight etc
um i didn't to be honest um i
tried to do as much as i could so
once i finished the chemo it was it was
quite hard because as i said i had the
energy
highs and lows from that um and i had to
isolate as well so i was almost doing
body weight stuff from home
if i felt good enough to i didn't force
that on on myself
so as soon as my isolation period
stopped
after about a month it was or five weeks
i think i could
slowly return to the club
but keep my my time at the club quite
limited
so literally just gym and a small small
return to running program
um and just built out from there really
and how did you go when you're back out
there did you feel like
the old johnny williams oh yeah
yeah yeah no it was good it was good
yeah it was a good good performance when
i when i came back
um well i was just happy to be playing
again you know you go from
from a hospital bed and realizing
there's other things to rugby
yeah to finally being able to enjoy
training and just enjoy playing again
for four days and really appreciate what
what i do for a living which is just
playing um
so it was just good to be back playing
really and not having the pressure on
performance
just just going out there and just doing
me i guess doing you
how good and then you obviously spoke
about your scarlett's move a little bit
before it was brought upon by
covert and then a massive offer from
scarlett's
huge coin and he just couldn't resist
no so i signed middle lock down so tiny
coin
had you finished newcastle yeah i was
out of contract yeah
so um yeah great opportunity arrived at
the scarlets
um which which i couldn't refuse
and was wales part of that deal was did
you have any
thing about wales included in their
offer or no
no absolutely no no so i thought if i
could
go to scarlets and try and nail the 12th
spot
um i thought i could i i'd hopefully get
into the team quite
quite quickly i had a goal the summer
tour yeah um
the one the one coming up but i was
named in the autumn squad which was a
massive shock i didn't think i'd get in
that quickly but
yeah that's that's what i mean by the
opportunity uh scarlets and
obviously i put two and two together and
i thought it was a great opportunity to
go and play for wales but
i didn't think it would come as quick as
it did yeah and how was it going into
that environment
international setup um different
hard the training the intensity of it
definitely jumps up the pressure as well
because
like whales and rugby's under the
microscope i guess
um at the minute in with covid and
obviously the press
um everybody wanting to know what's
going on in camp
who's doing well the pressures of
performance just
it goes up tenfold from from the
regional rugby i guess
um not to say i didn't enjoy it because
i loved it
it was really good and that was my goal
as i said from the start to
to get to that level and and play for
well so no it's amazing
did you cop any flak from the english
media or the welsh media
about doing that move because obviously
a lot of people would have thought you
were sort of
on the frame for england and then you're
probably one of the closest players to
playing
international rugby for two two
countries
um i i not that i read
i i was quite self-conscious of it at
the time
um but once the
once the um the announcement was made i
guess people put two and two together
that i
was going to play international rugby
for for wales
but without the promise it wasn't like i
was promised that um
so i guess people were saying i was
going
over there just like to play for wales
so yeah people did put two and two
together and
a lot of people were saying that i don't
deserve it after playing
in that england game and stuff so but
not that i i stayed away from it i
didn't
i didn't look at it i didn't read the
comments um
because just i know that would affect me
massively so
um i yeah i stayed far away from it and
once i started playing for scarlets and
playing well it they'd be gone
and people were saying i should be
playing for wales so
it comes and goes just as quick so stay
away from
stay away from the hate haters will
always hate hey but yeah how was it how
was your debut how was it leading up to
your debut the first time you got named
and leading into that first game how was
that yeah um
huge huge game again massive prior i
felt like after everything i've been
through it finally
all lined up um you know it was it was
seriously scary times with the cancer
stuff and then the covert thing
um wondering where i was going to play
my rugby but
just all you know the stars aligned for
the opportunity and i took it so
yeah it was massive and and seeing how
proud my family were for that
um it was just a shame they couldn't be
there because they've seen how much hard
work i've put into it as well so
um but no it went well we won um it was
a miserable night
in the rain so the rugby that was played
wasn't that great
but um yeah the occasion was massive and
it was
it was it was a moment i'll never forget
so what's it like playing your
international debut with no crowd it
started sort of not how you'd picture a
day
no i know i know it's crazy yeah i pre
pictured out the
principality and random in pakistan
so um but yeah i know it was it was
as i said it was a great game it was it
was a it was a
time on i forget um but yeah i was just
showing the crowd when they're eighty
thousand fans going mental
but instead man his dog
and then going forward a wee bit you i
wanted you to talk about your game
against
england because obviously um that would
have been a interesting one for your
emotions going up against
a lot of your ex-teammates or people
that you've been really close with
throughout your career how was that how
was that game
yeah so i was obviously really really
nervous for the game
um selected to start again i
you know not not so much doubts but
question marks if i could
you know really play at this level so
yeah played georgia played well in
georgia but
you know no disrespect but the standard
opposition obviously rose and
i'll be asked loads more questions in my
all in my whole game
so yeah it ended up going really well i
ended up going well
um we didn't get the win but
yeah it ended up going pretty pretty
well to be honest
so humble hey you're still very humble
humble left
such a humble lead you're on fire that
game
yeah no it was um here we go i had to
put in a lot of
tackles that's for sure we didn't have
much of the ball
but so my defenses are asking a lot of
questions so
sure but yeah that was a good game and
you usually rate your games on how much
guaranteed game line lightning quick
ball you got so it must have been hard
for you to just i know and i didn't get
much shotgun
but i thought it's a bigot
but are you now feeling really
comfortable in the whales environment
you feel like
you're a part of this squad now and
you're comfortable in there
yeah so yeah two camps um
definitely starting to feel yeah more at
home in the camp
um but again you never want to be too
too comfortable in that environment
there's always someone
you know one in your spot in there but
yeah no definitely
being familiar with the surroundings and
the hotel and and how things work
um but yeah as i said everyone's after a
spot in that camp so you can't get too
comfortable
yeah for sure and one thing we haven't
even talked about yet is your time at
scarlet so how
how was it going to scarlets what was
what was different about there i know
they're
pretty heavily attacking side so um you
must have enjoyed that yeah
yeah exactly um similar to newcastle and
the way we attack which was
get our hands on the ball get the backs
hands on the ball um which i felt like
sued my
my game um i felt like i could show what
i could do there um
and i'm loving it there the lads down
there great facilities down there
amazing
yeah the boys are class just just loving
it down there it's it's
yeah really good a few good kiwi lads
there too yeah
who do you know down there johnny mcnico
yeah what a lad what a lad he listens to
the broadcast
he listens to it oh i have to get him
yeah yeah
yeah yeah definitely blake thompson yeah
another lad yeah
skillful player yeah what a skillful
player what a player what a player
he's playing for scotland yeah we've got
some good players down there yeah yeah
he's up scotland um i think i think he's
concussed at the minute
so yeah
yeah i've heard that um in the past but
he's he's a great player be back and you
replace the goat hadley parks and
you're a big fan of hadley park oh taxi
yeah yeah um yeah i didn't get to meet
or
meet him so i don't know him but yeah
i've heard fantastic things about him
he was a great player and great lead you
two would have gone along like a house
on fire you two
you gotta get him on so many people so
many lads eh
i know i know so many seasons coming up
[Laughter]
oh so good but anyway what's your plans
going forward have you have you got much
of a plan how long are you with scarlets
um so i signed a three-year deal um
but yeah i'm i'm comfortable there you
know i could see out
my career there to be honest i'm loving
it um you know it's closer to home than
it was at newcastle so i see family
um i see family a lot more than i do
which is which is great
um living in cardiff and doing the
commute so i love cardiff
my girlfriend hannah loves cardiff um
yeah
just loving it mate it's it's going well
so yeah see
see him see myself being at the scars
for a while sure and you're only 24
that's real hard to believe and
how's the body is your body feeling
still pretty fresh and young you got it
you got another 10 years left in you
yeah yeah no sometimes i feel like a 30
year old
but after games when i'm when i've got
that gay night and guaranteed quickball
but um but yeah no i think
yeah if you do your recovery right and
um
you know the lock down as well would
have put a couple years of my old
24 year old body so but yeah the body's
fine mate
so as i said i'm still 24 still
hopefully got 10 more years left in it
oh what a career that's going to be man
i can't wait to follow that
have you have you got any plans uh after
40 have you started looking at that or
you're just going to probably
you'll probably retire straight after 40
with the amount of money
well adrian's making it i want to be a
wealth manager financial advisor because
i feel like i could do a better job than
him
and he's making serious money
talk to me about your time with adrian
wow there's not much to say because he
didn't do anything
hopefully yeah hopefully he doesn't
listen to this
that's all i got to say right jesus he
took my money and ran
the financial advisor so you're not
still with him
um i've just got a new one in cardiff
who looks after all the wells boys and
the boys rave about him so i thought god
i got a jump ship
just like you did i got out straight
away i saw the
red lights yeah you saw it
i was there like too scared to bloody
offend him
even though he's losing me so much cap
so
i finally pulled the plug but yeah i've
got a new one now
oh nice but what about after 40 have you
got have you got any plans what would
you love to do
no yeah i i was being serious i would
love to be a financial actually
yeah yeah a wealth manager yes
i've just started the course um with
cisi so yeah i've literally just started
that last week
it's gonna be good so yeah so yeah i'd
love to do that
um i'm doing a property development
alongside now in
in reading and hopefully that gets
finished soon and just
and just keep building for the property
portfolio
um wealth management would you be able
to look after my money
i haven't got all that cash
there's too much money there i can't
look after all of it
i lost it adrian took it all
yeah you spent it in afternoon
[Laughter]
oh what a journey what a career like we
said at the start so
many ups and downs geez what a what an
absolute journey
but as always we've gone to our
instagram for some questions and
like all international rugby stars
you've come up with so many questions
first question does he like a cider with
an overhead clap
is that who's that from are you allowed
to say who is from yeah that's from
willis hallo hollow
what's that one all about is it from ah
basically someone in the welsh squad
had a video from a stripper completely
naked
and they had their legs wide open like
this and
she just slammed her legs like that
so we just we just copy it we just do
the overhead clap
so that's what the overhead clap is is
this video from a naked stripper
but yeah so the side of it i don't know
because i hate cider
but yeah that's to give that context
and willis was in the room but i won't i
won't say who who the video was sent to
anyway oh jesus it wasn't winner
it wasn't it wasn't too late no it
wouldn't be willis he's a good kid
okay yeah how long do you spend doing
your hair before games
uh five minutes no nasty that's too long
see now
just a little a little bit look good
play good as tomorrow so
just a little bit a little bit what's
your routine though so what what's the
process
because it doesn't le yeah just a shower
yeah um and a little bit of a little bit
of product in not too much
and that's me that's me but yeah the
boys obviously
must think i uh spend a lot of time here
hair drying it and hair blowing it but
no that's not me that's not me
you've got a nice thick lid i think
that's the that's the thing eh
yeah it is thick snake
yeah i go to i go to the barbers and get
it thinned out meanwhile you can do with
something
you should have seen them all of your
thumbnail bits
yeah off the floor at the barbers and
just put it all together and put it on
his head glue it to his left
i'm sure he'd appreciate it snake of
speaking of snake if he's seen in a
question
as your builders has your builder sued
you for nearly killing him yet
no he hasn't all right so to give this
context um
i've got a house that i'm doing up in
reading save a bit of cash i thought i'd
do some
well i'd help out basically with my dad
and the builder
and there's an owl building out the back
that's big breeze blocks
um so we were on the back wall and
you know hammering down this this wall
but he last second as this wall's about
to fall down
decides to to go inside the building
so we push this wall onto it
this massive breeze blocked ball and
like
one breeze block lands claps in the back
of the head
scrapes all the way down him and there's
already breeze box on the floor so he
lands on all the
other breeze blocks that are already on
the floor and then this massive walls
just come tumbling on his head
i was in shock i thought i killed him
and my dad just didn't
didn't give a [ __ ] he was casual as you
like like you're right his name's stew
you're right sure i'll go get you a beer
from the co-op to say sorry
and meanwhile i was like oh my god i
almost killed this guy
i was in shock shaking but yeah
that's he's got a good memory snake
doesn't it he loves it yeah well still
right now is he is he still your builder
he does bits and bobs now he won't take
on massive projects after that
especially if i'm involved he stays away
if i'm involved
you do on his own but if i'm there
oh classic all right it's a good one so
next one
what's your favorite social this will be
good because you mentioned a few
few diesel ups and you you're obviously
a big man on the diesel you go
well you go good you go hard what's your
favorite one yeah
well we've had we've had a few good ones
haven't we um
there's always a standard fancy dress
one that's good we had a really good one
in london irish
where do you know the one where we did
the city slickers going on the boat
through town
remember that one i do i love that one i
remember scott still giving the middle
finger to all the
all the oaps on the side
even the middle finger and then we
literally just pulled up next to him
and got off the boat next to him and he
was just so awkward
that was a good one that was a real good
night um
so but again i can do you can do loose
or you can go and have a real good posh
night out as well where
you know you've got to be smarter
dressed to go to some nice clubs
yeah well that's supposed to be yeah you
both i'm versatile
you're very versatile social media
you can pull it all off oh good okay
next one
if there was one other club around the
world who would it be that you could
play for
i love watching super so
probably the
yeah i love tiles i'm getting ready
so i'd probably get the crusaders
relegated even though they cut
oh good one okay who's the hardest
player you've had to tackle
um i remember nathan
hughes almost knocked me out
it was like um our line out so obviously
10 back 10 back and turn over straight
to him off the line out and he had a
good 20 meter run up from
me and i thought oh my god do i step out
of the way or do i just go
part of this so i tried to chop him as
low as i could and i think
i almost died the wrong option
yeah yeah
yeah so um he's one that comes to mind
straight away
yeah um yeah manny tulane uh
obviously really hard yeah yeah i'll
probably go with those two yeah
nice good options okay who's the best
player you've played with this is an
interesting one you've played with some
great
yeah uh if you give me a minute i don't
know
i just kind of think man i gotta say you
you
you're up there jimmy
yeah the way you spoke about the game
like i just opened my eyes
you know like we had brennan vento
obviously
we're knocking the door down but yeah
the way
you spoke about the game and how we
wanted to play was
what was how i wanted to play so i saw
eye to eye with you on that
oh it's good people think this is a
stitch up of army out so you need
you need someone yeah yeah so
um obviously being at scarlets and being
a center
jonathan davis outside me he's he's been
a real good mentor for me
um and with his experience uh
he's he's up there we we've got
some really good big internationals
british and irish lions at the scarlet
so
i could name i could name a few of those
boys who are really good with their prep
um really professional but they also
deliver on the pitch so
i could i could name several from from
london irish newcastle and scarlett's
really
um but i would be here all night so many
so many good players
who's the best player in the world do
you think at the moment
i would have to say semi-rudrada
or dupont but yeah
i just watched semi-regrada's game and
not only is impossible to tackle
but he looks like he's got really good
hands i've heard he's really
professional
i've heard yeah and i've seen how how
much he carves up he's offloading game
yes his handling's good i don't
i just think semi-regrada but
as well do the way dupont
manages the game and he he's flarey as
well so
i probably i'll probably say those two
oh a couple of good options no kiwis
there interesting
richie mulano's on there yeah i thought
he was gonna be like
unbelievable i know you love it yeah
yeah i've been watching the canes he's a
good footballer
um
fair enough okay this is a good one
how have you handled setbacks throughout
your career obviously you've had a few
some really significant ones what's
what's the key to handling them
um how i handle it is by remembering
what's important but also then having
the goal
so in that time it was around being
around my family and friends
because i was deprived of that being in
newcastle so spending time with them
but then having the goal to get back to
rugby as soon as i could
to get to the top level so that for me
those two things were massive in my
in my bigger setbacks nice geez that's
good okay
last question what's the best piece of
advice you've had throughout your career
um this is this is a bit of a random one
but when i was when i was younger
um i probably lost sight of the goal a
little bit
and the teacher my pe teaching
who loved rugby was was also my
accounting coach and he could see that
i was a talent but he could tell i'd
lost a little bit of focus to get there
um and he just he just sat me down once
and was just he's he said that what he
fought and now i could get to the top
and all this sort of stuff but he said
you don't want to be that guy at the bar
who's
gonna say i could have made it and i
should have made it
and is now just saying to everyone i
didn't make it because of x y and z and
had
every excuse under the sun of why i
should have made it basically
but i had that chat when i was about 15
and it really hit home because i've i've
seen that around the rugby clubs i was
at where they
what they were saying they were really
good and they used to play for x y and z
but some injuries held them back
you know yeah and so once he said that
to me it it
um it really opened my eyes and why why
i wanted them to regain focus so it
wasn't so much of advice but he did sat
me down and gave me a bit of a
bollocking and said you could get to the
top here
stop pissing about basically jeez that
is that is some of the greatest advice
we've had yeah that's so good because so
many guys
how close they got to becoming a
professional rugby player i know
oh my knee just yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly so even
you hear that all the time you're here
all the time but even at 15 i knew what
it was on about
that and so i didn't want to be that guy
at the bar oh i could have been there
no that's not me i am there oh i like it
great advice what a way to finish
uh absolute great podcast john boy
you're an absolute legend it's been
awesome to see you
go through your journey and get to the
wales international side it's been
awesome to see
i obviously love playing with you at
london irish love playing off lightning
quick ball and getting that guaranteed
gain line you did it every time you're
an absolute legend
i'm looking forward to following your
journey as you progress hopefully
i'll see you out there for the british
and irish lions in south africa how good
would that be but
if not i'm sure you'll get to some
massive highs throughout your career and
yeah like i said looking forward to
following you so thanks
for giving up your time and coming on
what a land thanks for having me on
perfect